but we are going to begin with the
Fallout this morning from the failure of
one of the 20 largest banks in America a
bank with billions of dollars in assets
Federal Regulators have announced they
are taking emergency measures to make
sure to guarantee in fact the customers
of the now failed Silicon Valley Bank
will have access to all of their funds
starting today and President Biden is
expected to talk about this whole
situation just a little bit later this
morning we'll be following that meantime
Earl Barnett has made his way to Silicon
Silicon Valley Bank's headquarters
that's in Santa Clara California Errol
good morning not what you expected to be
doing when you took that West Coast trip
last week and we understand now a second
bank has failed good morning
Tony you are exactly right it's been a
wild 72 hours in fact this time though
its Signature Bank which failed that is
a new york-based financial institution
which dealt heavily with cryptocurrency
that bank will also have its deposits
covered as part of dramatic action over
the weekend and certainly during that
time there were concerns that we could
have been facing the largest banking
crisis since 2008 but that action by the
government to back deposit his money
swiftly seems to have staved off Panic
for now
the downfall of Silicon Valley Bank was
sudden and Swift at the beginning of the
year it boasted nearly 210 billion
dollars in assets and was brought to its
knees in fewer than 48 hours so whenever
a bank especially won like Silicon
Valley Bank with billions of dollars in
deposits fails it's clearly a concern
svb's demise story began during the
pandemic When the Northern California
region and its booming tech industry was
inundated with billion dollars in
Venture Capital Money deposits into svb
nearly doubled between 2020 and 2021 to
almost 200 billion dollars Awash in cash
and with interest rates at historic lows
the bank invested in something usually
considered safe long-term treasury bonds
and then what happens is interest rates
went up and the value of those bonds
went down so the value of the assets of
the bank declined last Wednesday svb
announced losses of nearly 2 billion
dollars that alarmed people says
Berkeley Professor Ross Levine all of
these depositors in the bank were told
by Venture capitalists that the bank
might be in trouble so all the deposited
at the same time went to take their
money out and it just wasn't funds there
we started hearing that there were some
liquidity issues at svb into Wednesday
night and Thursday morning Vanessa Wu
was General Counsel at Rippling a
workforce management platform which
handles payroll which was a client of
svb what happened on Friday
was we saw the funds Associated the
payroll wages associated with 66 000
workers leave our account and never make
it to employees and that's because
Federal Regulators had shuttered the
bank and so on Sunday night an
extraordinary plan was announced by the
treasury Department the Federal Reserve
and FDIC Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation one they say will ensure
depositors have full access to their
money by today a move they insist won't
cost taxpayers a penny when I read the
news I was certainly very relieved
Vanessa Pham founded Asian food startup
umsum with her sister Kim all of their
company's money was tied up in svb we
didn't know if come Monday what we would
have access to in terms of funds to be
able to do the basic things like you
know invest in inventory run the
business pay our team
so who's to blame here well there are a
number of people but critics are
pointing to the CEO of svb Greg Becker
he back in 2015 lobbied against certain
Financial regulations three years later
then president Trump signed a bill into
law which effectively lowered the
Threshold at which banks would need to
undergo stress tests that was 250
billion dollars and banks with those
types of accounts included svb and
signature Nate
Errol thank you